what is going on everybody welcome to a
robotics with Python tutorial video
series this series can be focused on
robotics with the Raspberry Pi as well
as the go PI go board now settle down
now
the go pi go is focused on keeping
robotics and programming as simple as
possible when it comes to the actual
robotics part and actually building a
robot wiring the robot and speaking in
the low-level terms that is required to
interact with hardware on say a circuit
board so the idea of the go PI go board
is to get you up and running as fast as
possible and this promise has really
held true by go PI go so you can put
this thing together you can build it in
ten minutes and that's not an
underestimation by any means so from
there what we can do with our go PI go
is we can put on things like we've got a
distance sensor here you've got a camera
here and then we can even weaponize this
with a missile system so from here we
can use a robot to serve a new territory
meet new and strange creatures and we
can even use the go PI go robot kit to
say patrol and protect our homes from
invaders so if that sounds interesting
to you guys
stays tuned there's a playlist link in
the description and let's get started
hey nope